Translator: Joseph Geni
Reviewer: Krystian Aparta
To kick the bucket,
bite the dust,
cash in your chips,
check out, depart, expire,
launch into eternity ...
These are all euphemisms we use in humor
to describe the one life event
we are all going to experience:
death.
But most of us don't want
to acknowledge death,
we don't want to plan for it,
and we don't want to discuss it with
the most important people in our lives.
I grew up in an Australian community
where people got old or sick
and passed away,
and only the adults attended the funeral.
My parents would come home
looking sad and drained,
but they didn't discuss it with us.
So I was ignorant to death
and of the grieving process.
At 15, I got my invitation.
A dear neighbor who was like an aunt to me
died suddenly of a heart attack,
and I attended my first funeral
and did my first reading.
I didn't know the tightness in my chest
and the dryness in my mouth was normal.
The celebrant got some of the facts wrong,
and it made me really angry.
He talked about how she loved knitting.
Knitting.
(Laughter)
He didn't mention that, at 75,
she still mowed her own lawn,
built an amazing fish pond
in her front yard
and made her own ginger beer.
I'm pretty sure "keen knitter"
isn't what she would
have chosen for her eulogy.
(Laughter)
I believe if we discuss death
as part of day-to-day living,
we give ourselves the opportunity
to reflect on our core values,
share them with our loved ones,
and then our survivors
can make informed decisions
without fear or regret
of having failed to honor our legacy.
I am blessed to lead a wonderful,
culturally diverse team,
and in the last 12 months,
we've lost five parents,
including my own father,
and most recently, a former colleague
who died at 41 from bowel cancer.
We started having
open and frank conversations
about what we were experiencing.
We talked about the practical stuff,
the stuff no one prepares you for:
dealing with government agencies,
hospitals, nursing homes,
advanced care directives,
funeral directors
and extended family members,
(Laughter)
making decisions about coffins,
headstones,
headstone wording,
headstone font size,
all while sleep-deprived.
We also discussed some of the issues
triggered by our various
cultural backgrounds,
and we realized there can be
some significant differences
in how we honor
the passing of a loved one.
A great example of this
is "Sorry Business,"
practiced by Aboriginal
and Torres Strait Islander people.
During Sorry Business,
family members will take on
specific roles and responsibilities,
protocols such as limiting
the use of photographs,
saying the name of the deceased,
and holding a smoking ceremony
are all a sign of respect and allow
for a peaceful transition of the spirit.
These customs can be a complete contrast
to those we might practice
in Western cultures,
where we would honor
the memory of a loved one
by talking about them
and sharing photographs.
So my lesson from this last year is,
life would be a lot easier to live
if we talked about death now,
while we're healthy.
For most of us, we wait
until we are too emotional,
too ill
or too physically exhausted --
and then it's too late.
Isn't it time we started taking ownership
of our finale on this earth?
So let's get going.
Do you know what you want when you die?
Do you know how you want to be remembered?
Is location important?
Do you want to be near the ocean
or in the ocean?
(Laughter)
Do you want a religious service
or an informal party,
or do you want to go out with a bang,
literally, in a firework?
(Laughter)
When it comes to death,
there's so much to discuss,
but I want to focus on two aspects:
why talking about and planning your death
can help you experience a good death,
and then reduce the stress
on your loved ones;
and how talking about death can help us
support those who are grieving.
So let's start with planning.
How many of you have a will?
Put your hand up.
Oh, this is fantastic.
In Australia, 45 percent
of adults over the age of 18
do not have a legal will.
You're a little bit above average.
This is a startling statistic
given that writing a will can actually
be quite simple and inexpensive.
So I started asking
my friends and neighbors
and was really surprised to learn
many of them don't have a will,
and some couples don't realize
they need individual wills.
The usual explanation was, well,
it's all going to go to my partner anyway.
So keep in mind that laws vary
from state to state
and country to country,
but this is what happens
in New South Wales
if you die without leaving a legal will.
Firstly, a suitable administrator
must be appointed
by the Supreme Court of New South Wales.
Chances are this is someone
who would never have met the deceased.
That person is then responsible
for arranging your funeral,
collecting assets and distributing them
after paying debts and taxes.
And one of those debts
will be the bill for their services.
This is not someone who would have known
you want the four-foot
wooden giraffe in your living room
to go to the person who helped you
carry it halfway across the world,
and yes, that's in my will.
(Laughter)
If you die leaving a spouse
or a domestic partner,
then chances are
they will receive your estate,
but if you are single,
it's far more complicated,
as parents, siblings, half-siblings
and dependents all come into play.
And did you know that if you make
a regular donation to charity,
that charity may have grounds
to make a claim on your estate?
The most important thing to know
is the bigger your estate,
the more complicated that will will be,
and the more expensive that bill.
So if you don't have a will, I ask you ...
when else in your life
have you willingly given money
to the government
when you didn't have to?
(Laughter)
I lost my father in February
to a progressive lung disease.
When dad knew his death was imminent,
he had three clear wishes.
He wanted to die at home;
he wanted to die surrounded by family;
and he wanted to die peacefully,
not choking or gasping for air.
And I'm pleased to say that my family
were able to support dad's wishes,
and he achieved his goals,
and in that sense, he had a good death.
He had the death he planned for.
Because dad wanted to die at home,
we had to have some
pretty tough conversations
and fill out a lot of paperwork.
The questions on the forms cover everything
from resuscitation to organ donation.
Dad said, "Take whatever
organs you can use."
This was upsetting to my mum,
as my dad's health
was deteriorating rapidly,
and it was no longer the right time
to talk about organ donation.
I believe we need to discuss these issues
when we are fit and healthy,
so we can take the emotion out of it,
and then we can learn
not just what is important,
but why it's important.
So as part of my journey,
I started engaging my family and friends
to find out their thoughts on death,
and how they wanted to be remembered.
I discovered you can host
a "Death Over Dinner,"
or a "Death Cafe,"
which is a great, casual way
to introduce the topic ...
(Laughter)
and gain some wonderful insight.
Did you know that your body
has to be legally disposed of,
and you can't just be shoved off a cliff
or set fire to in the backyard?
(Laughter)
In Australia, you have three options.
The two most common
are burial and cremation,
but you can also donate
your body to science.
And I am pleased to report
that innovation has touched
the world of corpse disposal.
(Laughter)
You can now opt for an eco-funeral.
You can be buried at the base of a tree
in recycled cardboard or a wicker basket,
and for those who love the ocean,
there are eco-friendly urns
that will dissolve at sea.
Personally, I plan to be cremated,
but given that I get seasick,
I can think of nothing worse
than having my ashes
flung into a huge ocean swell.
I've actually bought a plot
in the rose garden next to my dad.
I call it my investment property.
(Laughter)
But sadly, there's no tax deduction.
So if you plan for your death,
then your survivors will know
how to experience a healthy bereavement
without fear or guilt of having failed
to honor your legacy.
As part of my research,
I've been to seminars,
read books and talked
to palliative care nurses.
And I've come to understand
as a consequence
of not talking about death,
we don't know how to be around grief.
And on the flip side,
if we talk about death more,
we will become more comfortable with
the emotions we experience around grief.
I discovered, this year,
it's actually a privilege
to help someone exit this life,
and although my heart
is heavy with loss and sadness,
it is not heavy with regret.
I knew what dad wanted,
and I feel at peace knowing
I could support his wishes.
My dad's last 24 hours
were in a peaceful coma,
and after days of around-the-clock care,
we had time to sit, hold his hand,
and say goodbye.
He passed away on a Monday morning
just before breakfast,
and after the doctor came
and we waited for the funeral home,
I went into the kitchen,
and I ate a big bowl of porridge.
When I told some of my friends this,
they were really shocked.
"How could you eat at a time like that?"
Well, I was hungry.
(Laughter)
You see, grief impacted my sleep
and my ability to concentrate,
but it never impacted my stomach.
I was always hungry.
(Laughter)
It's different for all of us,
and it's really important
that we acknowledge that.
So if we don't talk about our death
and the death of loved ones,
how can we possibly support
a friend, a colleague, a neighbor
who is grieving?
How do we support someone
who has lost someone suddenly,
like an accident or suicide?
We tend to avoid them ...
not because we don't care,
because we don't know what to say.
We know as a friend we can't fix it,
we can't take away that pain,
so we say things
to fill that awkward silence,
sometimes things we regret saying.
Examples would be:
"At least he isn't suffering anymore."
"At least you've got your memories."
"At least you don't have to pay
for hospital parking anymore."
(Laughter)
Really, we don't need to say anything.
We just need to be.
Be patient,
be understanding,
and be a listener.
And if you can't be any of those things,
then please, be the person who makes
the lasagna, the curry or the casserole,
because your offerings
will be greatly appreciated.
(Laughter)
I've been to 10 funerals in the last year,
one of which I helped arrange.
They ran the full gamut:
a very solemn Greek Orthodox service,
four Catholic requiem masses
and a garden party
where I made a toast while scattering
my friend's ashes around her garden
with a soup ladle.
(Laughter)
I have carried, kissed, written on
and toasted coffins with a shot of ouzo.
I have worn all black,
all color and a party dress.
Despite the vast differences in sendoff,
despite me being at times
out of my comfort zone
doing something I've never done before,
I drew comfort from one thing --
knowing that this is what each person
would have wanted.
So what do I want?
Well, I like to be organized,
so I have the will,
I'm a registered organ donor,
and I have my investment property.
All that is left is planning my sendoff,
a big party, lots of champagne,
color, laughter, and of course,
music to remember me by.
Thank you.
(Applause)